the chemistry between the two of you is
hands down one of my favorite parts of
the movie
so how much of those back and forths
were in the script from day one
and how much of it evolved as you two
got to know each other better
i really love this odd couple too you
know and uh
this is like i think it's really
really really cool but um yeah so when
we started with
um with there wasn't that much in the
script
um we had like small a bit of ideas bits
and pieces but
especially uh meeting omari and
when we started to prep the film we had
so many ideas of this crazy couple
and and um so like every day we did a
lot of improv
and uh we were asking zach like you know
would it be okay if we do this and that
and
after why omari was wonderful anyway it
was wonderful
to work with omari because he was like
oh great there is even another space in
universe for my character too so we
could i throw this in and that and so uh
that was amazing to to create this this
like
we would say bromance and uh yes
yeah in that film definitely he allowed
us a space
he being the the legendary zack snyder
he would hate to you know always be
someone described as legend because he's
always
growing and he's a big he's a big huddle
guy so he was in the huddle with the
other actors you know with all the
actors and uh
we all love that we don't appreciate it
dave said yesterday in an interview dave
bautista
stated that zach was right there with
the camera you never felt like there was
the separation between director and
actor but
equally uh what makes him special is his
collaborative
uh space he gives so much space for you
to collaborate that
again matthias and i having never worked
with zach pryor
which most of the cast had not we we
think there's only one cast mate who had
worked with him
um and she in the form of a stunt uh
person during that film but
he allowed matthias and how to really
get down and add stuff and bring stuff
and so
these this duo of sorts definitely
developed as we got together
i absolutely loved it bringing up zach
now matthias what was it like
working on this set knowing that you
would eventually go on to direct your
own movie within this franchise
are you kind of watching him work and
taking notes or is that going to be
purely your own thing no no i watched
zach work and i was
pretty impressed like every day because
he's a visionary and he's like you know
i thought like oh my [ __ ] god how can
i do this or how can
you know i was pretty nervous but you
know like omari said
it's like to work with zach and and and
and to see him work it's
that's a that's another level so uh but
it's it's it feels like a mentorship is
the right mentor
mentor mentorship and um it was it was
pretty cool but uh we didn't know that
when we finished the movie that it will
be a prequel it was
it was way way after rapping so
uh that was like a big surprise but
uh omari and me we had you know we we
we were sitting together every day on
set and we were like
look at him that's that's a visionary
legend
oh my god can you please bite me or
beat me just or hit me just a short time
and so that was great yeah